so now like bring up the cast to fear
the walking dead please let me have a
huge hand for Madison Clark Jim [ __ ]
fans himself : Domingo and Felicia court
only to Devon carry as Jake Otto Sam
Underwood that's Roy Daniel Sharman
[Applause]
Jeremiah Otto Dayton Callie aphelion
Mercedes Mason and his Walker michael
gray eyes rounding out the panel here he
comes and ladies and gentlemen please
welcome Nick Clark rectally ranks down
here thank you guys thanks for being
here
it's been really fun to watch you get
comfortable with coming out in front of
7,000 people I remember a few years ago
when it happened there was a little bit
of a shell shock of like oh my god I
can't but this is are you guys feeling
more comfortable with it now is it it's
sort of feeling like part of the part of
the process for you we're more used to
it but it's it's there it's never not
exciting and and just like it gives you
chills well yeah because you guys you're
shooting out in Mexico most of the time
and so you're sort of you're isolated
and so you probably forget oh yeah we're
actually making a thing that people
watch and appreciate we're in a bubble
down there we come here so it's really
nice to see you all
so I'd predicted for a long time that
Madison had some really effed up stuff
in her past because she seemed so adept
at being able to adapt to these tragic
things and nothing really seemed to faze
her in any way and then of course
there's this big reveal that she
oh she had an abusive father and she
killed him and and she said she'd do it
again so what can you talk about in
terms of where she's at at this point
and then further like this kind of being
a figure for Nick and also to Troy at
the same time so where is she at at this
point the story look you know that
sequence were with the the reveal of
Madison's past and in this first half of
the season three was really satisfying
for me like I'd been suspicious too like
I didn't know Dave didn't really give me
the details but I'd been suspicious and
I kind of thought it was that that was
what she had done as a child and I
thought it was really beautiful the way
it came about like the with the fracture
between Madison or kids really
challenging her on why she was doing
what she was doing and it was this
beautiful moment where a parent becomes
a human to the to her child and I just
thought it was just a beautiful scene
and a beautiful story and I want to know
more I feel like there's more to know
still I was like we don't really know
how old Madison was we don't know what
happened to her after that did she go
into juvenile detention or whatever is
that what letter to be a high school
counselor and to care for troubled youth
and and does that give her this sort of
window into you know people with with
troubles and abuse issues and etc and I
think it did I think a lot of times
people will try to fix what they think
is wrong with them but this is the case
from Madison where it's like the thing
that was sort of wrong in her life is
probably the thing that's going to keep
her alive and keep her family alive now
right well she's a natural leader
like was one killer she is she what she
but she what it's she's a natural born
person who does things that need to be
done yes but she's it's ultimately from
her childhood ultimately at the end of
the day was about surviving and
protecting who she loved how do you
think a character like that because I
you know we see this in the Walking Dead
universe a lot you're like oh maybe they
you know the governor didn't start off
as a villain he started off as a guy you
know negan started off as a guy like
these people so how do you feel like a
character like Madison
once you start doing these things that
need to be done how does it not just
turn into bloodlust and how do you think
she balances still you know having a
soul and caring about people and not
just killing for the sake of killing
well I think it is it is a fine line and
that and I think you know she does have
to trade in brutality in order to as a
means to an end and the end being like
we've talked about it before it's like
you're it's the human instinct is to
build a community again and come
together and have a civilization and and
I think Madison is transitioning from
protecting her children and her family
and who have become her extended family
and in now protecting the ranch people
at the ranch or for you know finding a
truce and things like that and I think
that's how you know a successful leader
will transition with that the bad is is
only used when necessary for the greater
good right I think strand has had a
really fantastic our collective last
season because he really could have just
been a character that was just cool
about everything all the time that's how
he was presented in the beginning yeah
and what we learn about him is that he's
very complex you know he has this
relationship to Thomas that he I really
do believe he loved Thomas then that it
wasn't just all up even if it started
opportunistically I feel like he really
did love Thomas in the end and we've
seen him vulnerable we've seen him
imprisoned we've seen him lose
essentially everything so where is he at
and what's he what is he ready for at
this point in the story what's he going
to do just out there alone is he and
then I say that and then you put on the
sunglasses as the boat blows I see the
planes reflected in the glasses you know
it we talked a lot about that last
moment of stranding when he's walking
off any as you know as he's the
Abigail's in flames and where he's going
next and we made a choice to give him a
little glint in a smile it's very slight
but to see that he's ready to rebuild
again that's something that's just in
his nature he's been through devastating
circumstances probably since a child and
he's ready he's he's built himself up
and so we saw in season one was this
well made man of
civilization he was a bit of an enigma
and then it was deconstructed in season
2 and now season 3 it's he's still being
kicked taking the piss out of the entire
time but I think he's now on the mend
and as you see in the teaser and I don't
know first of all he's got a pretty big
old beard now and and he's now he's
grounded in a different way and things
have a bit more meaning for him and
waited with a bit more of as heart in
his soul and I think that's something he
was a bit more detached from earlier the
way we've been presenting with the
Strand well yeah so if you saw a from
the assumption that people who cannot be
trusted have a difficult time trusting
other people yeah do you feel like
that's something that he's learning how
to do or gonna have to learn how to do
because you really can't I think it's
very difficult to be a lone wolf in this
world he's had to learn how to do it and
it wasn't easy for him I think that's
been a huge learning curve form right
and I think then one that he trusts
trust the most is Madison right because
knowing that she's not she's one who's
she's fine with making the hard choices
and that's something that he was doing
that's why they bumped heads especially
in season two but they realized they're
more alike than not alike right Frank
Dillane had a watching Knicks what
happened with him this season and then a
couple episodes ago he's like okay well
I think I need to start learning how to
shoot a gun and learning how to fit into
this world do you think he is becoming
comfortable with what's going on now
instead of kind of rejecting it yeah I
think certainly has a gun and a knife so
I think so I think I don't know I mean
a guns are uncomfortable things in
general I think sigh I don't know how
come I don't really know what Nick
thinks I have to clear that up so I I
don't know you don't know I don't know
but there was definitely a transfer ask
him did you just push the hair down
hello I am Hank now well yeah we'll do
inside the access to do I'd like to talk
to Nick for a moment please
but but there what there definitely was
a transformation with him but it must
feel nice we did you know some of the
other English actors who came down on
the set did you did you did you know
these guys before they came down I
didn't know we've never met we don't
really know all know each other in
England there says it's really it's a
mess I don't understand I don't believe
that I see you all turn up on Doctor Who
and Downton Abbey and I just like oh
they all know each other there's like 10
of them and they all know it and we're
on an exchange program we get them they
can do good southern accents we bring
them over they can mumble it's great but
it is like you can you can either do
this you can talk down like that you
know it's like but it's fine you're
co-opting all of our superheroes all of
our Meg it's fine we're fine with it in
America we're very welcoming culture
mostly I was saying this we would say
exude when we were filming were in the
back of like this truck and they will
leave Indians going around and we're
dressed in my army gearing up for
America no no no I will know like
contact we have no like in route to this
now I've just not in our culture right
leave Native Americans running about
guns and like I have no idea what I'm
doing
Englishmen in the back of like a sport
take our time what we do in here then
insult I would say because Jake just
stays at home reading probably the most
English however it does yes yes he has
just had a spot of tea but I do but is
but it is always nice anything for
people to and I think it is a testament
to your acting ability because it
happens a lot on talking dead where the
first time you come on you know and
they're like yes well I have a coach the
character people like you know like it's
just when Lennie James was on the first
time we were like he's British like and
he ever sees snatch he's amazing and the
guy's amazing here's why I don't think
you like the Downton Abbey thing goes
reverse because when you do an English
accent if you're almost almost goes
always to what I don't know that's all
too many so second time actually I know
this is always the only British I
understand this Monty Python right right
that's it that's where I get it was like
five accents from Monty Python or C so
this guy or like you and this is
Doubtfire well one quick fair enough
one quick thing I'd say about Franklin
Nicks before we move on because I think
Frank has actually played this
beautifully I mean you're it's a very
challenging position that Nick ends up
in by the end of the season and I think
he has he's definitely adapted and he's
taken on aspects of the apocalypse that
he didn't have before but he's also in
this strange position where he's getting
close to things that are more violent
than he's accustomed to and one of those
things is his mom strangely you know I
mean so I think we get to a place by the
end of the mid-season where he's
actually now in some respects you know
the the tortures have passed so it does
it sets it sets you up in an interesting
way for the back half and I think it's
and I just I think it's really lovely
how you've played him
I'll see you past seasons I think it's
also interesting to see as someone who's
in recovery for alcohol addiction from
the last 14 15 years it's really
interesting to see a character whose
addiction actually because his addiction
and the world that he was living in
before actually is weirdly a strength in
this world because he's so used to just
the darkness and in the chaos and that
he you know he because it as an asset
because he becomes very comfortable in
this kind of a world which you know
transitionally was feels like was not
that different to him for what he was
going through but Alicia had also had a
big season this year Alicia with an I
had a big season this year so there
seems to be a lot of not animosity but
there's definitely friction with the
fact that and I think some of it is just
because Alicia is such a capable strong
character yeah that Madison not hasn't
really ignored her but definitely has
put more of her attention into Nick
because she's had to yeah and Alicia has
learned I think very much like her
mother to be a survivor so do you see
her to be just like independent
completely self-sufficient she's had to
be from
our young age but it's nice I feel like
we're finally seeing especially with
when the information of what happened to
the Trimble's actually comes out that it
was trying that they covered for him
that's a real divider in that moment I
think it starts the question Alisha's
relationship with how far that family
bond has to go and cover up certain
secrets you know what I mean right like
it yeah and like kind of what but it's
funny because Madison is all about
family and it's it's interesting to see
how she's gathered another extended
family with the autos and kind of she
Alicia's been with her and taking over
the ranch to a certain extent or like
going along with this but once this
happens as a real fracture and I think
it's nice to finally see that alicia
make up her mind of what's too far and
what family actually means and what
version of family is she really talking
about you know that's kind of
interesting as well for that what do you
think how do you think she's viewing
what's going on with Jake like what do
you think she sees that as being
everyone asks me this question
the inquiring minds wanna know Jake and
Alicia we sure and Jane well the reason
I had come it doesn't just doesn't just
feel like oh here's a female character a
male character let's just get him
together yeah I just like she was very
much kind of using him as a distraction
yes no I think it's actually really
interesting I got a lot of comments on
social media about about it a lot of
people were annoyed that they had a
young female character that once again
being brutal standing next to another
male boyfriend kind of character and I
know you you and I talked a lot about it
as well I'm having real trouble with
like where to look with this microphone
I'm like moving around crazy but I think
this is nice it's a nice moment to show
that this is actually a young person
trying to just be normal and
and fill in some of the gaps that were
she missed out on through college and
her youth and having to grow up too fast
in this apocalypse and it doesn't have
to be about her falling in love with
someone or her being with someone but it
is a natural part of life wanting to
have companionship and needing it beyond
what is it like romantically but also
where your to people who are codependent
codependent presence you know what I
mean it's good it doesn't have to be
that relationship and I think that's
what's nice about it is Alicia goes for
it it's her decision she it's a much
more mature decision of I like this
relationship we have but it doesn't have
to ground my entire exist it doesn't
define you does not define you but it
also doesn't mean you don't have to have
it right because in real life people
have all those relationships and it I
think I know we're in a tricky sort of
very political correct time where
everything's very hard to define you
want to be able to define everything but
I think it's nice that this relationship
is a little kind of messy and confusing
and doesn't really ambiguous it is
ambiguous and that's okay and it doesn't
define Alicia also like the show itself
does such an amazing job of proving the
point that women don't need men to
survive that is like a foundation of
what the shot it really is so we did
talk a lot about it because if anything
I see Jake is being a character that is
really trying to bolster up Alicia being
a leader like that's what it is it's not
about the dependency Dietl yeah but it's
also like two people honoring each other
mm-hmm and not like a home I mean you're
so right by the way also first of all a
huge hand for cliff Curtis who portrayed
Travis but Madison almost like fractured
her spine carrying him for two seasons
around cuz he didn't want to do anything
you know like no I don't know maybe he's
just like shut up stab that guy we need
information that's pretty but Sam how do
you how is Jake fitting into everything
and you know
he obviously is he's he's he's very
intellectual and he's very academic and
he feels like words can solve everything
I actually didn't trust his character at
first because anyone who's anyone who
speaks too articulately in The Walking
Dead universe I'm like well they're
going to murder everyone like that's
what they're this is a this is a this is
a preliminary to a monologue I'm still
alive so yes do you have to lay yeah but
it does it does it does seem like at
least for the information that I have
that he is that he is a good guy how
have you seen as an actor have you felt
fitting into this pre-existing world
well I think the Jake represents in my
opinion he represents much in a similar
way as Cliff's character as well did in
season 1 and 2 of being a moral compass
believing that there is still good in
humans again acting is very relevant
right now in the zeitgeist that's out
there is that there are people that
still are idealists and an optimist
optimistic about the future of humanity
so when you put them in a zombie
apocalypse there are some people that
still have that need to want to connect
a community through whether it's you
know what the founding fathers did a
constitution or a democracy but
civilization needs to include civil
civility and this is a world where there
are no rules anymore the moral and
ethical ambiguity that's out there is
pretty strong so Jake represents that
need and it's kind of interesting that
he's one of the only people that truly
is just dedicated to that violence is
not his thing and yeah I mean we'll see
how that you know it turns out in
general but I think he's an important
character as a reminder to the audience
that yeah the world is pretty [ __ ] right
now and this this world in the show is
pretty [ __ ] right now
but there has to be that on that face
that things can still get better because
otherwise it's just you know everything
will crumble and for Troy for Troy's
character he's it definitely seems like
he is more let's just run in and shoot
things rather than talk to them yeah I
do I think actually that I think
the writers this season have done a
really beautiful job with all the
characters and I think with Troy is no
exception I think what they've written
is but yes of course on the outside
there's a hotheadedness detroy that I
think you know obviously allow to
certain actions that seem very kind of
morally reprehensible but like well I
think they do a really beautiful job
with this they they make they make him a
puma beings and therefore his actions
and his things as we'll see later in
this in the season as well at a they
they are based in a real it can have a
real understanding of he has of his own
upbringing of his own place and and I I
don't see I I never saw him as a hothead
I think it's more important that he
believes very clearly that this is this
is about the survival of everybody here
what is happening between Troy and
Madison because there are some times
where it's like oh we needs a mom looked
like you might be aroused like it feels
like there is definitely in the sort of
gray area and she and again this is you
know just the brilliance and the
strength of Madison Clark is she so
understands how to push people's buttons
and she so understands and she spotted
Troy's weak spots immediately right and
basically he was eating out of the palm
of her hand after she tried to scoop his
eyeball out with an iPhone like that's
right read of all but I don't but you
see is I I don't I don't think that's
how you know for me I don't try I think
he loves playing this game I think he's
well aware that he's being played I
don't think there was this idea that
like he does he's blindsided by
something I think he's smarter than that
I think it's they're smarter writing
than that which is he understands that
he's still being played but just the
fact that he gets to play this game he
gets to play this chess game in which he
gets to look like he has been fooled
it's part of Troy loving Madison being
you know it's it's it may seem very
one-sided but Troy's as much as as much
playing that game as she is and I think
he is enjoying the fact that she even
thinks she has the upper hand so it's a
very complex ideas I think say
everything that is an excellent point
and I'm also jealous of your
beautiful windswept British hair can't
not ready to do it
Dayton Caliban what bands at the same
time new fans at the things I gloat
about Dayton Cali who I was a huge fan
of before for many things particularly
Deadwood but you've always you've always
popped up in things that I enjoy and
what are you going to miss the most
about playing Jeremiah Otto oh I guess
being a loving caring understanding fog
will be the hardest part to let go like
you know I'm just sat here quietly for
the last 15 minutes with you listening
to these Brits and Australian talk
really sophisticated again any castaway
[ __ ] but you don't know what they do
when they say cut as soon as they say
cut it was all in [ __ ] done it they
don't talk like noises I think the bloke
Aziz what'd he say what'd he do lug nuts
they just go into their own little code
you know that they have been it's been
wonderful listen you had some stuff to
get out that's all right we're a therapy
group you know it's like we this is
share session everything owns a stone
you don't know I think it's fun I think
when you were on talking down I said you
know what do you what do you like most
about Jeremiah Otto and you go the
paycheck I think that's what is it as a
joke but it was wonderful to have you on
the season and I'm sorry I'm sorry that
you died but it was a very important you
know I teach the kid how to shoot a gun
and what does he do takes her head yeah
they got to take your head he shoots you
and then I got it they got to take your
head Mercedes did this really great
runner on talking dead of where's
Ophelia this sort of like the Bob Dylan
desk with the
the cards like where's the failure to
love actually yeah love actually of
course yeah that's right which was taken
from Bob Dylan ah yeah I knew that but
but I would love to because she seems
we've we've got the luxury of being able
to see these characters transform and
their arc but we see a feeling she's not
the same a feeling we saw when she
disappeared before so who is she and
whose side do you think she's on and
what's what's going on good lord um I
mean when we meet her she's daddy's
little girl with the braids to the side
and one of the things I wanted to do as
we see her again when she thinks she's
orphaned is sort of keep a throwback but
a more boldly version of can I say
that's ballsy you just said it twice so
I did a more hammer face version of a
philia where I wanted the double braids
I wanted to show that she still who she
is but she's realized now finally that
she is her father's daughter and she has
to do certain things to survive so she's
finally become a bit of a badass I can't
wait for her to meet back up with Daniel
Salazar so he can see what she's become
for them to go on a killing duo for them
to go under - yes Satan tell him about
our baby guys I'm so sorry he wasn't
supposed to spoil dad episode 13 of
Celia and Jeremiah Otto had a beautiful
moment a baby was born of it oh but um
he wasn't supposed to spoil and I'm
really sorry you guys beautiful baby
obviously now in my care because you're
dead so but looks just like you yeah um
so I'm really sorry about the spoiler
you guys but now you know that magic
telephone they already got magic
telephone so everybody
yeah yeah I don't feel your baby Michael
Gray I've Walker is such a great
character and this story is such an
interesting story in this world and and
and and I don't I mean I guess
technically I don't even I don't really
see him as the as a villain I don't see
this guy I see this as a man who this
was you know this was his family's
ancestral land it was you know he's
Jeremiah is not the easiest person to
deal with so but how has this storyline
been for you and and and you know
certainly as a teacher and all the
things that the things that you're
involved in
how do you pay respect to it in a way
and what's been exciting for you
I love playing Walker I'm so excited to
be on the show I was a fan a huge fan of
The Walking Dead and this show before I
came on so when I had the chance to
audition
you know I first read you know the
material they gave me I said this guy's
so smart and then I found out as I
learned more about the role he was a
former lawyer and so for me as somebody
who's really interested in in
representation and and understanding how
media works in terms of our community I
was delighted to be able to play a
character who was vigorous and a leader
intelligent articulate and brutal and
strategic because it within two episodes
within you know two sort of full
episodes he's kind of turned the entire
ranch inside out and he ends up a you
know co-opting Madison you know this
really strong character into his plans
and they and you know at the end of
child of wrath you know Kim and I are on
the ridge and all of a sudden she's
handing me a bag with with Otto's head
in it so to me you know my mouth fell
open when I when I turned the page on
that script and I was like like this is
one of the most fantastic characters
I've ever had to play my name is
Kimberly first of all I want to just
thank you all for giving us such strong
female role models and happy birthday to
Alicia with the way particularly
[Music]
[Applause]
people one more time what is your
question um will we or do we want to see
an effective Travis and will we get to
see what happened at the hotel Wow which
Wow
and we get to see infected Travis no
okay well for a number of reasons it was
it was never planned that way and also I
think cliffs now a little bit busy
working with mr. Cameron yes I knew I
might talk to him so I don't think we
could get him back even if we wanted to
so and then what happened at the hotel I
mean as far as maybe I mean I think will
will it's going to be up to I think what
comes going to season for if we ever go
back to that go back to that place and
see what happened to also Elena and
company there I always thought it was
kind of clear because it was so just
bloody and and there was just it didn't
end well it didn't didn't know nothing a
good happen there but but we didn't get
we didn't get to see how how they how
they would survive it or did not
you